allez on on s'y met bonjour messieurs
merci de votre présence à cette audition
ravi de vous avoir avec nous je vais
commencer par la
rituelle prestation de serment requise
devant une commission d'enquête
parlementaire je vous rappelle qu'un
faut témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vais vous inviter chacun d'entre vous à
prêter serement de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité à lever la main
droite et à dire je le jure ça peut être
fait
collectivement merci
messieur ce qu'on vous propose selon
l'usage établi c'est que vous commencez
par une petite présentation liminaire et
puis ensuite on nourrit le feu roulant
des questions pour aller chercher les
réponses à toutes nos interrogations je
vous en prie dans l'ordre qui vous
convient
ah pardon mesdames et mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs donc
du coup pour ce propos limininaire je je
vous proposais de de faire une petite
description de la compagnie avec une
présentation locale et les conditions
dans lesquelles j'ai pris mes fonctions
il y a 6 mois donc pour pour sur la
problématique des stupéfiants avec un
état de la menace et puis en deuxième
partie plutôt les conséquences des des
des des infractions sur la législation
sur les stupéfiants les moyens qu'on
emploie et pour finir les difficultés
que nous rencontrons avec quelques
propositions donc la compagnie de
gendarmerie départementale d'ancement
argenttin donc c'était c'est une
compagnie qui est composée de neuf
brigades donc neuf brigades pour la
plupart en communauté de brigades un
Ploton de surveillance des interventions
de la gendarmerie dis saabes donc c'est
des personnels qui sont tous d'Activ et
formés le spectre du du terrorisme et
enfin une brigade de recherche donc la
compagnie est située dans l'Orne c'est
un c'est un département qui est plutôt
de passage qui est frontalier avec six
six départements et qui qui se trouve à
moins de 200 km à l'ouest de Paris on
couvre 97 % du du territoire de du
département principalement en zone
rurale et ça correspond au 3/4 de la
population donc le reste est géré par la
police nationale donc la
présentation pour ma part ce qui est
important ce que je voulais vous faire
vous vous vous évoquer c'est quand vous
prenez le le commandement d'une
compagnie vous avez une appropriation
territoriale c'est un département que
que je ne connaissais pas que je
découvre et en qualité de com de
compagnie je suis responsable de la
sécurité publique donc sur le territoire
et par conséquent je suis impliqué par
tous les contentieux qui sont commis sur
le le département sur le sur ma partie
de la compagnie mais qui va au-delà des
infractions aux stupéfiants donc
néanmoins conformément aux directives
que j'ai reçu quand je suis arrivéin le
ministère de l'Intérieur qui a été
décliné localement par le groupement de
gendarmerie il y a deux priorités qui
sont fixées depuis plusieurs années et
qu'on m'a qu'on m'a qu'on m'a donné en
arrivant c'est les violences intra
familiales et les stupéfiants et dès mon
arrivé il y a 6 mois donc ces deux
priorités m'ont été rappelé par le le
com groupement et par les autorités
judiciaires puisque j'ai été reçu par
les deux procureurs de la République
vous avez le le parquet d'Argentan et
d'Alançon et par l'autorité
administrative donc moi ce que ça me dit
quand j'arrive parce que j'ai servi dans
d'autres départements qui sont un peu
plus urbanisés c'est que j'ai servi dans
l'Est de la France le nord de la France
près de près de lî et la dernière
affectation d'administration centrale en
région parisienne c'est qu'un
département comme Lorne euh qui est
particulièrement rural n'est pas épargné
par le fléo des stupéfiants voilà je
pensais en arrivant on me dit tout de
suite que voilà les stupéfiants c'est
une problématique quoi et euh c'est tout
le sens en fait à alançon donc on me
rappelle aussi un petit peu la jeunèe de
ce qui s'est passé avant que j'arrive
c'est le comité interministériel de
lutte contre les les stupéfiant qui a eu
lieu à Lançon qui réunissait le Premier
ministre et les ministres concernés de
l'Intérieur euh notamment de la justice
et des comptes publiques et aussi on me
rappelle que quelques mois avantarriver
en janvier 2023 il y a un plan de lutte
contre le le craque qui a été mis en
place à alançon euh ce plan implique les
forces de l'ordre mais pas seulement il
implique l'agence régionale de santé la
préfecture la mairie enfin tous les
partenaires qui ont qui ont besoin d'en
connaître donc même si alançon alançon
n'est pas en zone gendarmerie donc même
si Alençon relève de la zone police
malgré tout la gendarmerie est également
associée à la lutte contre les les
stupéfiant euh et si le trafic se situe
essentiellement sur Alençon la zone des
consommateurs s'étend sur tout le
département de l'Orne voilà donc on on
est conscient que la plupart du trafic
est sur Alençon mais pourtant ça irrigue
tout le département de l' donc par
conséquent le contrôle des flux est
stratégique et dans cet esprit donc on a
un groupe local de contrôle des flux qui
a été mis en place en janvier 2022 qui
est chargé justement de de traquer les
approvisionnements stupéfiants en
substance illicite et du coup on a un
groupe de qure militaires donc qui est
commandé par l'adent chef Vernet qui est
sur ma gauche qui aura l'occasion
également de de vous présenter son
travail et des problématiques qu'il
rencontre dans ce cadre là actuellement
ils sont quatre la difficulté c'est que
c'est sous plafond des effectifs donc
donc ce cette difficulté normalement
devrait être surmontée dans les années à
venir puisque dans le cadre des 200
brigades ces postes devrai être
pérénisés à hauteur de 6 personnels donc
nous on récupérrait des postes pour nous
faire autre chose et six personnels
seraiit
affectés définitivement à cette tâche
alors je voulais vous faire un état
aussi de la menace et ce qu'on trouve
sur notre secteur donc sur la
circonscription on trouve tout types de
de drogue effectivement du cannabis de
l'héroïne de la cocaïne de la
métamphétamine et d'autres types de
drogue et concernant le crack on n pas
eu de saisie importante ou alarmante en
tout cas j'ai même pas de saisie depuis
6 mois que je suis présent sur la
compagnie mais ça veut pas dire que il
n'est pas présent sur la circonscription
voilà c'est pas parce qu'on a pas fait
de saisi donc on est attentif à ça et
l'objectif du plan craque également
c'est d'éviter qu'il ne s'étende
justement la zone gendarmerie c'est pour
pour ça qu'on est attentif concernant la
cocaïne on constate qu'elle s'est
démocratisée malheureusement parce
qu'elle a perdu son image négative
qu'elle avait par le passé de la
seringue et du reste et qu'en plus les
prix ont baissé sur la délocalisation
des trafics en zones rural nous on peut
l'exprimer par l'expliquer par plusieurs
raisons c'est que les fournisseurs
cherchent la
discrétion dans les zones rurales la
clientèle les plus restreinte et connue
des fournisseurs la délocalisation aussi
en campagne elle permet aussi le
développement de le phénomène de
canibiculture hein avec le matériel que
vous trouvez facilement sur Internet et
qui est en vente libre et en plus pour
la culture vous trouvez des tutos
facilement sur Internet pour vous
montrer comment faire nous sur la
circonscription j'ai pas eu euh depuis
les mois de ma présence de grosses
découvertes de de de de de
cannabiculture en indoor on fait des
saisies de temps en temps de pieds de
cannabis donc ça veut dire que ça existe
on a des on a des pieds de cannabis qui
sont saisis une quarantaine sur la
compagnie voisaine et nous une dizaine
donc on a aussi ce phénomène là on a
aussi les investigations enfin la
l'accessibilité à tous les produits en
deux clics sur Internet donc ça aussi
c'est un phénomène qu'on rend compontre
et on se rend compte puisque ça ça
favorise aussi les petits délinquants
qui peuvent s'improviser facilement
dealer justement grâce à la
disponibilité des produits sur internet
et je voulais évoquer aussi sur le le
sur le constat de ce qu'on peut trouver
sur le secteur c'est aussi de la
livraison donc les uber sheat si vous me
permettez l'expression qui sont apparu
avec des fournisseurs de grandes villees
alors de ville limitrophes au
département de l'Orne qui viennent
approvisionner notre secteur alors ils
ont des modes opératoire assez assez
facile he il récupère des listes de
téléphones d'usager le matin avant de
partir il diffuse les produits
disponibles au consommateurs et il livre
sur le département en différents points
avec un conducteur qui est chargé d'être
toujours en mouvement et le passager qui
se charge qui se charge de ventere voilà
donc on est loin c'est pour ça que
j'avais pris volontairement ces exemples
là on on est làun des points de Deal
traditionnels qu'on peut rencontrer même
si on a des points de Deal dans des
pavillons ou des logements collectifs
qui existent également donc les
conséquences du trafic sur la
circonscription donc ça génère des
infractions connexes c'est sûr par
contre qui sont difficiles à quantifier
donc on sait que ça génère des
infractions type d'appropriation des
vols des cambrillages pourquoi pas des
vols à main armé mais aussi alors je
peux également évoquer des règlements de
compte alors c'est pareil je je vais
évoquer cet exemple parce que c'était
c'était récent c'est durant les les 6
mois où j'étais présent il y a quelques
mois on a constaté que deux individus
qui voulaient recouvrir une dette de
stupéfiant auprès d'un usager
consommateur dealer qui devait revendre
pour sa consommation personnelle et ils
l'ont donc ils sont pénétrés dans son
logement l'ont abimé d' liquide
inflammable en le menaçant de le brûler
ils sont retranchés dans le logement
donc ce type de règlement de compte a
nécessité bah l'intervention de la
brigade locale du Ploton d'intervention
et effectivement ça aurait pu ça aurait
pu être beaucoup plus grave donc on a
réussi à interpeller les individu et
voilà ça s'est bien passé mais à travers
cet exemple ce que je veux montrer c'est
que la ruralité n'est pas épargnée par
ce type de fait qui est particulièrement
grave et euh par contre ce que je veux
dire également c'est qu'on peut pas
faire d'un fait particulier une
généralité parce que on on on est lucide
sur le constat ça existe pour autant euh
c'est pas comparable à ce que vivent
certaines grandes villes voilà mais on n
pas que effectivement ça arrive
également chez nous voilà mais c'est pas
mon quotidien voilà sur les 6 mois c'est
arrivé une fois alors les moyens euh sur
une deuxème partie donc les moyens en
fait l'action moi ce que je vois et ce
que j'avais vu je me sers aussi de de
mon expérience passée hein euh c'est que
l'action elle est globale elle peut pas
être seulement sur la dimension
judiciaire et répressive donc elle se
base aussi euh sur la prévention et
notamment auprès des plus jeunes donc
sur si je fais le parallèle sur ce qu'on
fait avec les plus jeunes moi je l'ai vu
avec la rentrée des classes on a fait
beaucoup d'informations sur la
cybermenace le harcellement on fait la
même chose dans le cadre des stupéfiants
avec l'intervention des formateurs
relais anti-drogue et euh si je veux don
donner quelques chiffres le bilan 2023
on a sensibilisé plus de 4200 personnes
qui ont été sensibilisées dans ce cadre
là essentiellement des scolaires donc au
nombre de par exemple 93 classes plus de
2300 personnes en milieu scolaire
professeurs encadrement y compris voilà
donc on agit aussi dans le cadre de la
sensibilisation stupéfiant avec des
partenaires comme la CPAM les services
de santé les bailleurs sociaux avec qui
on travaille également à qui on peut
faire ce type de de de d'intervention
sur si je fais le lien entre la
prévention et et la répression parce
qu'on va on va aussi parler de la
répression on a aussi la présence de
voix publique alors c'est quelque chose
auquel je tiens beaucoup j'en parle
beaucoup à mes personnels c'est quelque
chose je remets fréquemment pas
seulement parce que c'est une directive
de mes chefs mais c'est un argument
aussi mais c'est parce que j'y crois en
fait les gens les les les la population
est contente de voir ces gendarmes mais
moi je le vois quand je me déplace je je
vois les les personne on a les gens qui
sont contents de nous voir ça peut les
rassurer c'est difficilement
quantifiable on a a des gens qui sont
moins contents de nous voir et ben cela
tant mieux je veux dire et et et on est
présent pour ça pourquoi parce que la
présence bon ça permet de générer de
l'insécurité chez le délinquant ça
rassure la population nous ça nous fait
détecter les trafics et rechercher du
renseignement donc pour ça on multiplie
les patrouilles on organise aussi des
des opérations antidélinquences sur des
qui qui qui est utilisé également pour
les lutter contre les cambriolages et
d'autres faits hein pas seulement les
stupéfiants mais en matière de
stupéfiant souvent les contrôles qu'on
fait c'est avec avec le maître chien
détection stup et sous réquisition du
procureur qui nous permet de faire des
ouvertures de coffres et voilà de créer
de
l'insentiment malheureusement si je
parle de répression c'est que notre
présence pour indiguer le phénomène ne
suffit pas c'est sûr que si on faisait
que ça ce serait pas ce serait pas
optimal donc comme je le disais notre
action doit être globale alors elle est
globale parce qu'on mène aussi des
enquêtes judiciaires les enquêtes
judiciaires plus ou moins longues en
fonction de l'importance du trafic et de
la complexité du trafic
et pour cela on exploite les
renseignements qu'on obtient sur le sur
les secteurs on élabore des stratégies
sous la direction des des deux parquets
des procureurs de la République et notre
plus grande force c'est de pouvoir
agréger des moyens locaux à des moyens
nationaux que ça soit au moment des
investigations mais aussi au moment de
la phase opérationnelle avec les unités
d'interpellation d'intervention qu'on va
utiliser en passant de la brigade au
Ploton d'intervention jusqu'au gygine si
nécessaire et ça cette force là c'est
grâce la subidarité des moyens et
hiérarchiques qu'on peut avoir c'est
quelque chose que que les élus voyent
enfin qui est plus visible notamment sur
les recherche de personnees quand vous
avez une personne qui disparaît on monte
en puissance on peut passer de deux
gendarmes à 10 gendarmes 20 50 s'il faut
puisqu'on va agréger les moyens locaux
voire nationaux en fonction d'eux et en
parallèle si c'est une disparition
inquiétante on va avoir une phase
judiciaire qui va monter donc ça c'est
notre force de pouvoir agréger ces
moyens-là
euh et moi je vais vous donner enfin je
vais pour illustrer mon propos donc je
je vous donner le l'exemple de de de la
disparition de personnees mais pour
rester dans la thématique des des
stupéfiants pour illustrer le propos une
intervention qui a eu lieu il y a pas
longtemps on avait un renseignement sur
des des trafics de stupéfiants par voie
de drone voilà donc ce renseignement a
été exploité euh on a utilisé de la
technique spéciale d'enquête on a
utilisé un aréoscope qui nous permet de
de faire de la traçabilité du drone pour
l'identifier et l'objectif c'était aussi
de de matérialiser les infractions ce
qui nous a permis donc je reste sur le
l'aéroscope cet exemple nous montre que
moi localement je dispose pas de ce type
de matériel mais il a pu être fourni par
la région voir par l'administration
centrale et ça nous a permis de de
matérialiser 51 51 livraisons pour plus
de 20 kg de de produits stupéfiants
livrés au centre pénitentier d'argenttin
voilà puisque cette personne alors je
vais vous donner le profil parce que
c'est aussi intéressant de voir sur qui
on travaille on est sur une personne
sans emploi qui est titulaire d'un Bac +
2 et qui était motivé pour le coup par
par ce que générait ce que générait
financièrement l'intérêt d'un trafic
d'un trafic comme celui-là
quoi alors je finirai mon propos par les
difficultés quelques quelques
propositions donc les difficultés qu'on
a c'est que les techniques
d'investigation qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui sont parfaitement connues
des délinquants et ça c'est un vrai
problème même si on essaie d'innover en
permanence la téléphonie n'est quasiment
plus utilisée par certains délinquants
et quand ils le font ils changent
jusqu'à 20 fois le numéro de téléphone
dans le même mois donc ça c'est une
difficulté l'usage aussi de la data et
des messageries crypté éphémèr
aujourd'hui puisque la messagerie on
fait aussi des saisies de téléphone donc
ça ça nous permet à postérior de de
rechercher à l'intérieur mais maintenant
on a même de la messagerie éphémère donc
on a on a même plus vraiment accès en
remplacement des écoutes on a eu la
sonorisation mais qui s'est aussi
démocratisé et par la transparence des
procédure lié les délincants aussi ont
été informés aussi de de l'utilisation
de la sonorisation donc aujourd'hui il
se méfi de ces procédés là on a
l'approche patrimoniale j'y reviendrai
dans les propositions qui est
intéressante mais qui est difficile
aussi puisque les délincants utilisent
aussi des de nouveaux moyens pour
transférer les fonds donc sur quelques
propositions mais après je je je répond
enfin nous répondrons à aux questions je
mentionnais le volet patrimonial à
travers les les confiscations donc elle
montre toutes leur efficacité c'est
certain Paris que voilà mais en même
temps il faudrait qu'elle soit plus
systématique parce que on le voit et je
pense que les magistrat que vous avez
reçu auundi on a plus d'appels sur les
confiscations que sur les peines de
prison elles-même et le le principe de
se dire que le crime ne doit plus payer
euh et est un principe qui est efficace
quoi on constate aussi sur les peines
complémentaires l'interdiction de
sesjour voilà ce qu'on a constaté à
travers ces peines complémentaires
l'efficacité du déracinement
géographique quand vous prenez le
délinquant et qu'il a une interdiction
de de de séjour sur le lieu où il a
commis les fait souvent il a du mal
aussi à à reprendre voilà euh
USS où je suis duci la difficulté qu'on
a c'est aussi que quand on tape un
trafic enfin quand on quand on
solutionne on travaille sur un trafique
c'est pas efficace à long terme soit
parce qu'ils vont recommencer soit parce
qu'il va être remplacé donc voilà d'où
le déracinement aussi géographique donc
le rêve des enquêteurs mais ça voilà
serait l'interception des messageries
crypté mais bon on est sur quelque chose
de voilà de plus difficile j'évoquerai
aussi la simplification de la la
procédure pénale qui souffre parfois
d'un manque de de lisibilité et aussi
qui est de plus en plus complexe et pour
nous la procédure surtout elle ne doit
pas obérer l'agilité et la souplesse
dans nos investigations pourquoi parce
que ils sont nos délinquants sont très
réactifs et qu'il faut que nous aussi
soit on soit très réactif et la
procédure bon dans une démocratie elle
doit être on doit être travailler en
transparence et et être contrôlé c'est
normal mais il faut qu'elle soit agile
et souple euh je parlerai aussi de de
l'AFD de de l'amand forfaitaire
dtellctuelle on propose it aussi en une
extension de lafd à au mineur alors je
sais que ça se ça se heurte à des
difficultés constitutionnelles néanmoins
voilà ce serait ce serait aussi une une
un avantage pour nous et et sur les
propositions je finirai par
l'encouragement à la Visa à la à la
vidéo protection alors moi je sais que
je travaille beaucoup avec les élus on
en parle beaucoup sur le développement
de la de la vidéo protection dans les
dans les communes ce que j'ai identifié
comme rétisence parfois bah c'est
l'impression pour les citoyens d'être
surveillé d'être voilà donc je pense
qu'il faut les rassurer en se disant que
que les dispositifs sont faits pour pour
les protéger et pas les surveiller eux
au quotidien dans leur vie personnelle
donc ça fonctionne puisqueil y a
beaucoup de communes qui s intéresse de
plus en plus et je finirai sur le la la
vidéo protection forcément si on a
beaucoup de vidéos sur le développement
de la vidéo donc voilà on parle d'
d'intelligence artificielle mais de
d'outils pour nous aider à exploiter la
vidéo puisque la vidéo est est très
c'est très chronophage d'exploiter de la
vidéo protection donc je pour conclure
je en conclusion fusion donc vous
l'aurez compris le département de l'Orne
bien que majoritairement rural et assez
éloigné des grandes métropoles n'est pas
exemp de la présence de trafic de
stupéfiant voilà donc j'en veux pour
preuve je vais citer quelques saisis et
vous allez voir vous allez voir qu'elles
sont bien dans ce là de certaines
grandes métropoles mais elles sont quand
même parlant plus de 4 kg d'héroïn pour
2023 soit le double de l'année
précédente plus de 20 kg d'herbes et de
résine de cannabis mais soit le double
de l'année précédente et pour autant on
est mobilisé voilà en relation avec les
partenaires les services partenaires et
il existe une vraie stratégie globale
que j'ai évoqué le volet préventif à à
destination des plus jeunes et et de la
population et aussi également le volet
répressif d'une part en dissuadant les
consommateurs donc vous verrez aussi
avec le glcf par l'occupation de la voie
publique et les contrôles qu'on peut
faire sur le terrain en ayant recours
aussi aux AFD et d'autres part en
démantelant les trafics par
l'utilisation d'enquête judiciaire
voilà merci beaucoup premier exposé je
propose d'enchaîner Mons le chef
d'escadron très bien je vous remci donc
je suis le chef d'escadron sans ch en la
compagnie de de Saint-Quentin et je suis
accompagné du major chet4 qui est mon
commandant de ma brigade de recherche
donc mon unité de police judiciaire
dédiée dédiée à la
compagnie je vais essayer parce que
beaucoup a déjà été et beaucoup de
choses très intéressantes et pertinentes
ont déjà été dit par mon camarade je
vais compléter en vous présentant de
manière
synthétique la compagnie le contexte de
ma compagnie et ensuite vous dressz un
petit un un un petit portrait
effectivement de des trafics tels que
nous les constatons sur notre ressort et
les mesures que nous essayons de de de
prendre pour pour y remédier donc la
compagnie Saint-Quentin se trouve
géographiquement dans le car nord-ouest
du département de l'INE nous sommes
limitrophes par le nord avec le
département du Nord par l'ouest avec le
département de la Somme ce qui nous
oblige entre guillemets en tout cas nous
permet également de coopérer et de
collaborer avec avec nos camarades des
des compagnies et et groupement voisin
euh j'ai la charge avec mes militaires
de la sécurité de 85000 habitants sur
une circonscription qui fait grosso modo
60 km Est-Ouest pour 40 nord- sudud donc
ce qui veut dire que nous avons 2400
km² à surveiller avec 155 communes sur
cette circonscription donc une très
grande multiplicité de d'interlocuteurs
communaux
avec au milieu de cette zone une zone
police nationale donc la l'agglomération
cquantinoise qui elle représente environ
70000 habitants et 5 communes et donc un
commissariat de police avec des
effectifs également dédiés un peu plus
particulièrement à la police judiciaire
et pour pour ce faire donc je dispose de
111 militaires qui sont répartis en
quatre communautés de brigades une
brigade des recherches donc commandée
par la major CIT 4 qui qui est à côté de
moi et un pleoton de surveillance et
d'intervention de la gendarmerie voilà
donc avec ces militaires là nous devons
assurer l'ensemble de la sécurité
publique de la circonscription mais
également de fait lutter contre les
trafics de stupéfiants phénomène qui à
l'instar de ce que vient d'exposer mon
camarade n'est évidemment pas absent de
ma circonscription et nous sommes
effectivement confrontés à des à des
trafics de stupéfiants de la
consommation et également des trafics à
plusieurs niveaux sur lesquels je
reviendrai tout à l'heure et pour vous
donner une idée assez générale sur
l'année 2023 ce sont tout confondu quel
que soit le niveau 65 procédures qui ont
été tré pour des infractions à la
législation sur les stupéfiants
impliquant 95 personnes 95 mises en
cause ces chiffres sont très voisin
voilà de l'année 2022 donc pas pas de
baisse mais pas d'augmentation
significative sur l'année 2023 avec
toujours cette précision qui me semble
que que vous connaissez mais mais qui me
semble importante de de de de ramener
c'est-à-dire que les statistiques en
matière de
stupéfiant peuvent ne pas être
effectivement représentatif complètement
puisque par définition la recherche des
infractions liées au
stupéfiant ne Val que si on va les
chercher entre guillemets et à à
l'inverse des atteintes aux bien
classiques ou des atteintes aux
personnes les victimes viennent signaler
les fait don don elles ont été l'objet
alors que le consommateur de stupéfiant
le vendeur de stupéfiant par définition
ne viennent pas ne viennent pas signaler
et également un chiffre qui qui est
important puisque j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure et ça a déjà été avvoqué avant
moi sur l'importance de la de de du
traitement des avoirs criminels à noter
quand même une amélioration en la
matière puisque en 2022 les effectifs de
la compagnie avaient saisi l'équivalent
de 26000 € en avoir criminel et on est
passé à 56000 € sur l'année 2023 donc ce
qui marque quand même une prise en
compte de cette de cet aspect des
investigations euh pour ce qui est plus
particulièrement du trafic de
stupéfiance sur le ressort de la
compagnie euh ce que je note moi c'est
euh évidemment avec avec le major mais
une très large prééminence de la cocaïne
et c'est vraiment la cocaïne qui nous
impacte le plus sur notre
circonscription ce qui ne veut pas dire
que les autres produits ne sont pas
présents nous avons et nous sommes
également confrontés à à de la résine de
cannabis à de l'herbe de cannabis à de
l'héroïne mais l'immense majorité des
trafics sur lesquels nous travaillons
des saisies que nous pouvons effectuer
des contrôles positifs que nous pouvons
effectuer font ressortir de la cocaïne
et c'est vraiment c'est vraiment le
produit entre guillemets phare et c'est
celui que nous auquel nous sommes
confrontés le plus souvent et je
correobore ce que disait le chef
d'escadron bas tout à l'heure euh
la démocratisation si on peut l'appeler
comme ça et effectivement la notamment
la baisse des tarifs font que de plus en
plus ce produit devient plus accessible
et non seulement par la baisse du tarif
entre guillemets au gram puisque non là
on parle de de de fin de chaîne donc de
consommateur mais ce que l'on note
également c'est que là où il y a encore
peut-être quelques années les achats
pouvaient se faire plus facilement au
gram maintenant ils se font ce qu'on
appelle par par parachute donc par 0 10
g ce qui veut dire que le consommateur
qui a peu de moyens pour 10 € va pouvoir
acheter son 0,1 g là où il aurait
éventuellement payé 60 € voir peut-être
un petit peu moins maintenant pour
certains pour certains réseaux 100 g 100
g de de cocaïne voilà donc pour
clarifier tout de suite ce ce que vous
dites la cocaïne est le premier produit
ou c'est celui qui vous occupe le plus
qui qui a le plus de dynamique de de
vente de consommation les deux pour moi
c'est vraiment les deux même même
effectivement dans une circonscription
qui vous l'aurez compris en dehors en
dehors de cette de l'agglomération
cquantinoise donc urbaine et très
urbanisé mais tout le reste de notre
territoire est un territoire très rural
malgré ça je je vous dis pas qu'on
trouve pas de cannabis on trouve du
cannabis sous la forme d'herbe ou sous
la forme de résine mais ce qui ce que
l'on constate le plus souvent ce qui
nous a ce qui nous ce que l'on découvre
dans nos dans dans nos enquête mais
également dans nos contrôles de de voie
publique c'est vraiment c'est c'est la
cocaïne qui prend qui prend le pas sur
sur les autres produits ça c'est le
premier constat euh le second on a quand
même des cas de cannabiculture et alors
avec avec une amplitude très importante
puisque encore une fois je je je ne
parlerai que de ma circonscription parce
que celle que je connais le mieux mais
on n pas de nombreuses cannabicultur
mais on en trouve assez régulièrement le
plus souvent très majoritairement dans
des petites quantités plutôt sur des
gens qui cultivent pour eux-mêmes voir
selon eux pour dépanner entre guillemets
quelques quelques amis qui s'adonner
également à la consommation mais on peut
avoir comme ça a été le cas début 2023
en janvier 2023 donc il y a un an
maintenant la découverte d'une
cannabiculture industrielle avec plus de
2000 pieds et plusieurs chambres de de
pouss qui ont été découvertes mais là où
on était vraiment en périphérie
immédiate de de la de l'agglomération
cinquantinois et qui manifestement bon
je je n'irai pas plus dans le détail
l'enquête est encore en cours mais avait
de ce qu' l'on en sait plutôt vocation à
être la culture à repartir ensuite et ne
pas forcément à irriguer le le marché
local voilà
pour
qui est d rapidement brosser le les les
sur les produits sur les profils de de
trafic que comme je viens de l'évoquer
on est on est face à deux grandes
typologies assez classique de l'usager
revendeur qui est d'abord usager et qui
pour essayer de faire face à au cût de
sa propre consommation va va se mettre
le pied à l'étrier d'abord par des
achats groupés puis euh par l'achat de
plus en plus régulier voire en revente
pouvoir se payer sa propre consommation
et qui le le comment dire les les ventes
se succédant va commencer à tirer du
profit et à essayer de se
professionnaliser et enfin et le deème
grand profil de trafic auquel nous
sommes confrontés celui qui nous
inquiète le plus dans nos communes qui
sont des plutôt des petite commune on
constate depuis plusieurs années moi je
suis présent je suis en poste que depuis
un an et demi mon Pr ur le le le déplor
également et ça se confirme nous sommes
de plus en plus confrontés à des réseaux
structurés extérieurs qui sont implantés
dans des agglomérations des grandes
agglomérations de la région haute-fance
voire éventuellement parisienne mais le
plus souvent Haut- de-fance ces réseaux
projettent sur nos communes des
vendeurs vendeurs souvent très jeune
voire assez régulièrement mineur très
certainement pour pour se jouer de de la
procédure par particulière il les
projettent chez des consommateurs
parfaitement identifiés de nos communes
qui les accueillent contre rémunération
qui le plus souvent est leur
consommation quotidienne voilà et donc
ces domiciles de consommateur identifiés
deviennent des points de Deal deviennent
des lieux de revente et qui peuvent être
éphémères et qui peuvent rester 15 jours
3 semaines 1 mois puis changer si si la
la relation avec le le logeur n'est plus
bonne ou si il y a eu interpellation le
vendeur est perdu mais on en renvoie un
quelques quelques semaines voir quelques
jours plus tard chez un autre
consommateur qui le plus souvent
l'accepte de fait voyant le profit qu'il
peut en tirer mais parfois n'a pas le
choix et il est il est entre guillemets
menacé de représaille si s'il met pas à
disposition son son logement voilà et
c'est c'est plus particulièrement ce
type de réseau qui qui nous inquiète de
fait et ça a été également évoqué tout à
l'heure mais euh ce que l'on peut dire
autour de ces trafic c'est que nous
sommes assez peu en tout cas notre
connaissance confronté à ce que il est
convenu d'appeler des gardes de
territoire entre réseau voilà ce qui ne
veut pas dire que ça ne peut pas arriver
mais on y est assez peu confronté pour
l'instant on a quand même quelques actes
de violence que l'on peut constater sur
fond de de trafic alors avec la
particularité que comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure pour les
statistiques lié aux investigations sur
les stupéfiants de fait là lorsqu'une
dette de stupéfiance se règle entre un
vendeur et un acheteur l'acheteur a
assez peu envie de venir se signaler aux
gendarmes mais il arrive de temps en
temps qu'on qu'on nous appelle sur
l'instant et qu'après on nous refuse la
coopération ça nous est arrivé il y a
encore quelques semaines où en pleine
nuit on est appelé parce qu'il y a une
agression et lorsque on sait que les
gendarmes interviennent les agresseurs
s'en vont et au moment où les gendarmes
arrivent et demandent à à vous pouvoir
faire les constatations et et a effectué
les constatations à l'intérieur du
domicile la victime ce mur refuse ferme
tout et on en entend plus jamais parler
voilà en gros on nous appelle quand on a
besoin mais après on veut on veut
évidemment plus collaborer donc on est
face à des victimes de ce type de fait
qui évidemment ne ne collabor que que
très très peu voir pas du tout euh
au-delà de ces quelques actes de de de
violence auxquel on peut être confronté
on a effectivement la délinquance
d'appropriation et encore pas plus tard
que la semaine dernière trois vols avec
dégradation commis sur des monayeurs de
station de lavage sur des sur deux
communes de de ma circonscription qui
une fois les auteurs interpellés
lorsqu'on les interroge sur le pourquoi
avoir besoin de cet argent là bah
c'était pour aller tout simplement
acheter le la dose de cocaïne nécessaire
donc effectivement c'est en revanche il
est difficile de
quantifier le rôle et le poids exact de
la consommation dans cette dans cette
délinquence là mais clairement
clairement elle existe c'est c'est c'est
sûr quelqu quques conséquences également
sur ce que sur ce que l' appelons sur ce
qu'il est convenu d'appeler chez nous
les les atteintes à la tranquillité
publique bon sur fond de de de tapage
également ou de Rix voilà qui peuvent
être commises alors soit à l'occasion
comme je l'évoquéis tout à l'heure de
différents sur fond de stupéfiant mais
après tout simplement également sur sur
fond de de de prise de de
stupéfiant sur sur la réponse locale que
le que nous essayons de de mettre en
place ça a été évoqué par mon camarade
mais évidemment que la première de
celle-ci c'est l'action de voie publique
donc c'est d'abord la surveillance de la
voie publique et la connaissance par les
gendarmes des brigade de leur population
et de l'évolution de ces populations et
de savoir qui consomme qui peut être
amené à revendre qui n'est pas
habituellement qui n'est pas qui est
inhabituel dans le paysage et pourrait
éventuellement s'adonner au trafic donc
on a évidemment cette recherche de
l'information et cette recherche du
consommateur voilà qui est
traité prioritairement par nos gendarmes
de brigade on a également de l'autre de
l'autre bout du spectre là les les
soldats du major à côté de moi qui eux
sont sont là pour travailler sur le fond
des dossiers et pour essayer de démler
les réseaux à notre niveau je m'entends
euh mais j'ai eu j'ai eu à faire la
constatation avec avec mes militaires
qui on on on avait on avait un
entre guillemets allez on va dire un
trou la raquette entre les deux entre la
le contrôle de voie publique le
brigadier le gén de de de PSIG qui va
chasserentre guillemets le le
consommateur qui va contrôler des
véhicules qui va contrôler des personnes
à pied al avec ou sans réquisition ou
avec ou sans mettre chien de l'autre
côté les enquêteurs qui sont de de fait
amenés à faire des investigations qui
vont être longues parce que amener la
preuve de la culpabilité amener la
preuve de la structuration du réseau euh
ça demande du temps et entre les deux on
je je trouvais qu'on avait un trou donc
le choix que l'on a fait nous au niveau
de la compagnie c'est de créer un groupe
de lutte contre les stupéfiants euh qui
justement et a pour voocation de combler
ce créneau entre le contrôle simple et
l'investigation long cours voilà donc
depuis la mi-octobre a été mis en place
donc ce fameux groupe de lutte
antistupéfiant armé à 5 militaires dont
le travail et à partir du renseignement
collecté de même par laab ou par les
gendarmes de brigades de mener des
investigations courte de vérifier les
informations au plus vite et pour aller
pour aller sur des interpellations
rapides et pour des traitements
clairement en compartion immédiate voilà
donc avec les maintenant quasiment 3
mois de 3 mois de recul euh c'est un
système qui fonctionne plutôt bien euh
qui amène des résultats et qui amène des
résultats mais au-delà du résultat
immédiat une meilleure connaissance du
des des des consommateurs et des et des
usagers revendeurs puis si les
informations sont positives et que ça
demande des investigations en plus long
terme à ce moment-là il rebasc il passe
le relais aux enquêteurs de la brigade
des recherches mais voilà je pense qu'on
on vient combler on vient combler un
vide qui existait et de d'investigation
courte mais qui ne pouvait pas être
traité par les GES de brigade qui qui
sont déjà pris sur beaucoup d'autres
missions maintenant cette solution pour
moi je je vois qu'avantage avec
peut-être la difficulté mais on y
reviendra très certainement que ce
groupe il est créé évidemment sous
plafond et donc il est créé avec les
effectifs dont je dispose déjà de
manière native et que de fait lorsque je
retire enfin lorsque je prends ces
personn pour créer un groupe àhoc euh
bah je les retire des unités dans
lesquelles ils servent habituellement et
de fait les unités dans lesquelles ils
servent habituellement disposent d'un
militaire de moins pour effectuer les
mêmes missions mais voilà il m'ait
semblé intéressant que de de de le faire
et et pour l'instant c'est plus c'est
plutôt positif sur l'échange
d'information euh nous échangeons
euh bien et plutôt efficacement avec nos
camarades des compagnies voisines quel
que soit leur groupement he les
compagnies de notre groupement ou les
compagnies du groupement du Nord ou
groupement de la Somme euh les relations
sont sont bonnes avec les policiers du
commissarat de Saint-Quentin et
notamment avec leur sûreté
départementale enfin ils viennent de
changer de nom puisque euh a été mise en
place la Direction Départementale de de
la police nationale depuis le 1er
janvier mais les enquêteurs restent les
mêmes et les les relations sont sont
bonnes et la collaboration est est bonne
et il y a pas de il y a pas de phénomène
de concurrence entre nous on a
suffisamment de de de travail euh voilà
et donc la l'aspect collaboration est
est plutôt positif sur
les difficultés ou en tout cas les
propositions que que auxquelles nous
avons pensé de notre côté alors qui qui
reviennent peu ou pro à celle que à
celle dont qu'a évoqué le le le chef
d'escadron bas tout à l'heure mais le
premier le premier levier d'action à
notre sens en tout cas à mon sens c'est
l'action sur les consommateurs
euh les trafiquants les revendeurs
viennent tout simplement là où ils
savent que se trouvent des consommateurs
si nous avons des réseaux qui
proviennent d'agglomération extérieure
qui viennent implanter des vendeurs sur
certaines de nos communes c'est parce
qu'ils savent que là ils ont
effectivement des prospects tout
simplement euh donc l'action sur les
consommateurs on parlait d'fd tout à
l'heure je rejoins complètement ce que
disait mon camarade au-delà du fait
qu'elle pourrait être alors évidemment
en fonction de ce qui sera décidé par le
législateur bien sûr mais étant du au
mineur mais on a peut-être le montant
aussi de la FD puisque actuellement le
montant de la FD si ma mmire bonne est
200 € qui peut être minoré à 150 voir
majoré à 400 ou 450 bon pour un
consommateur au-delà au-delà du
consommateur récréatif qui va peut-être
s'adonner à une prise occasionnelle dans
l'année le le le consommateur régulier
bon je pense qu'une AFD à 200 € ça lui
fera pas forcément peur enfin il ira il
retourne il y retournera quand même avec
la difficulté que la FD ne peut pas être
relevé un récidiviste voilà bon ni un
mineur ni un récidiviste donc on a cet
aspect de la FD euh je j'abonde
également
j'insiste fortement sur ce qui a été dit
avant moi sur les confiscations et de
fait je pense qu'il y a déjà en interne
ce travail est mené et on continue à le
mener sur la formation de tous nos
personnels et sur les réflexes
patrimoniaux et de confiscation enin de
confiscation de saisie à notre
niveau pour le le pour les pour les
trafiants usagers au vendeur et même si
c'est même si ce n'est qu'un véhicule
que du numéraire qu'un téléphone que
voilà tout ce qui peut être prix entre
guillemets au trafiquant doit l'être
parce que c'est ça effectivement qui les
marque plus que la prise en ferme même
si la prise en ferme à mon sens peut
avoir tout son intérêt mais le
trafiquant l'a intégré dans le risque
lié à sa fonction et à son métier en
revanche la confiscation si en plus de
la prison ferme on on repart avec la
voiture on repart avec le téléviseur on
repart avec les mes de luxe voilà ça
c'est c'est c'est très c'est très
intéressant et la difficulté que l'on a
c'est que tout le monde n'est pas tout
tout le monde n'est pas pas forcément
parfaitement formé à cela et les
confiscations ne sont pas systématiques
à l'issue des saisies
euh voilà pour cette aspect là euh
également je je je j'abonde également
tout à fait dans ce qui a été dit sur
les peines d'éloignement peinees
complémentaire et effectivement le fait
de pouvoir interdire un territoire à un
trafiquant peut être particulièrement
intéressant pour nous puisque même si
soit le trafiquant exécute ou en tout
cas souscrit à cette interdiction et
c'est parfait pour nous même s'il peut
agir riurs mais ou alors il il s'y
soustrait mais on a des moyens de
réinterpeller de placer en retenu et
d'aller vers une une nouvelle une
nouvelle condamnation ou en tout cas
l'ajout d'une ligne supplémentaire sur
des antécédents qui à un moment ou un
autre fera finira par faire tomber par
faire tomber ce délincant et enfin sur
les aspects de de l'enquête et de la
surveillance effectivement je souscris
également à ce qui a été dit sur le fait
que tout ce qui peut
entre guillemets alléger ou assouplir la
procédure et
évidemment serait évidemment positif
pour nous et pour les enquêteurs qui qui
la traitent au quotidien et
effectivement également pour nous
développer des moyens d'observation et
de surveillance puisque et je reviens
effectivement les difficultés actuelles
et un effort pour être mené technique
sur la cryptologie et sur effectivement
toutes ces toutes ces messageries qui
qui nous pose beaucoup de difficultés et
qui encore plus qu'à l'habitude nous
oblige à aller recueillir et c'est bien
normal mais nous oblige à aller
recueillir des éléments de de preuve des
éléments matériels par l'observation et
la surveillance sur le terrain avec la
difficulté bah que pour pour procéder à
des observations de surveillance bah il
faut des véhicules et il faut des moyens
et il faut du personnel et que c'est
très chronophage et et que c'est demandé
par tout le monde donc les unités
spécialisées ne sont pas ne sont pas
toujours en mesure de de de répondre à
toutes les sollicitations et en interne
nous le faisons également mais pour
prendre l'exemple de la la brigade de
recherche de Saint-Quentin mais je je
sais que c'est la même chose du côté de
d'Alançon argenttin mes enquêteurs
spécialisés entre guillemets sont à
l'effectif de 7 voilà et 7 il traitent
tout il traitent du stupéfiant il trait
de l'atteinte aux bien il trait de
l'atteintte aux personne de de la
délinquence économique financière enfin
voilà
voilà et enfin sur les moyens de
détection puisque on est également de
plus en plus en difficulté sur notamment
là je je prends l'aspect plus
particulier du CBD ou des drogue de
synthèse pour lesquels le gendarme sur
le bord de la route pour reprendre une
image une image d'épinale mais sur le
bord de la route a des difficultés à
faire la différence dans un si vous
prenez une cigarette électronique avec
un liquide transparent allez savoir si
c'est du si c'est du comment dire de du
tabac liquide ou si c'est du pè ton
crâne comme on l'appelle maintenant ou
du boud Blou sur le bord de la route
c'est actuellement c'est pas simple
etfin c'est même impossible voilà voilà
en en quelques en quelques comment le le
le portrait que je souhaite dresser pour
LAAC compagnie de 50 ans merci beaucoup
mant n nous enettons à notre rapporteur
merci une question vous avez parlé de
réseau organisé extérieur organisation
extérieure qui
ensuite pénètre votre circonscription
vous les connaissez ces réseaux comment
est- ils sont organisés combien de
personnes il y a une répartition des
fonctions est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire quelque chose est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si vous avez la
capacité de remonter à cette tête des
réseaux ou les moyens qu'il vous
faudrait pour le
faire alors euh la bonjour vous voulez
peut-être répondre allez
oui bonjour major chatanttoine du coup
commandant la brigade de recherche de
SaintQuentin chargé notamment ben des
enquêtes contre lutte contre les
stupéfiants euh moi je noterai
principalement nos difficultés en fait
c'est ces enquêtes nécessite beaucoup
d'observation et donc amener la preuve
de quelque chose on a des moyens à
disposition par type appareil photo et
cetera mais on manque bien sûr bah de de
matériel des véhicules par exemple
banaliser des choses comme ça pour nous
permettre d'approcher au plus proche
justement euh des réseaux euh ensuite
bah il y a aussi maintenant comme l'a
indiqué le commandant on a des réseaux
qui viennent d'assez loin donc on est
obligé de se déplacer également pour sur
les lieux donc on arrive quand même à
remonter mais après bah il faut pouvoir
traiter comme une unité comme la mienne
à 7 bah il nous faut des fois par deux
trois enquêteurs à plein tempemps pour
ça donc c'est une difficulté mais on a
on a la possibilité mais c'est ça reste
toujours difficile pour nous d' monter
le plus haut possible quand vous parlez
d'organisation de ces réseaux vous avez
une tête qui approvisionne elle-même
elle s'approvisionne mais là vous n'êtes
pas
là-dessus vous êtes sur la tête qui
approvisionne votre secteur et ensuite
comment vous pouvez lancer des
investigations sur l'argent qu'il
récoltent
sur les appartements qu'ils occupent sur
leur mobilité
et cette notion de réseau pour nous elle
est très importante pouvez nous
détailler un petit peu cela alors euh
pour reprendre des alors sans rentrer
encore une fois dans les détails mais
sur sur les enquêtes qu'on a pu mener
sur sur sur le territoire effectivement
ce que l'on constate à notre niveau
encore une fois c'est que on peut avoir
une une tête de réseau sur une
agglomération extérieure qui lui-même va
disposer d'un d'un lieutenant qui va par
exemple s'occuper de de la livraison
puis peut avoir
euh achète et ensuite un lieutenant
c'est ça qui livre qui livre qui livre
Le le point sur lequel son le vendeur a
été a été installé tris personnes voilà
et on constate de plus en plus que l'on
peut alors ponctuellement mais avoir
également un autre membre du réseau qui
est là pour assurer un rôle qui se
trouve entre la nourrice et le
surveillant et le et un peu le coffre
fort donc qui va être qui va être plus
amené à s'assurer que la livraison se
passe bien que le vendeur ou le logeur
n'est pas tenter d'aller se servir dans
l'argent ou dans la marchandise et qui
va régulièrement venir récupérer le
numéraire qui provient du trafic pour ne
pas le laisser voilà sachant que point
point important mais parce que on l'a
pas évoqué mais je pense que c'est
important pour nous de de vous le
préciser c'est que les trafiquants
s'adaptent très vite et du coup
désormais on est amené nous à constater
des livraisons de de sur des faibles
quantités de produits parce que les
trafiquants ont très bien intégré que
sils sont contrôlés s'ils sont
interpellés euh ils vont perdre la ils
vont perdre le produit et mieux vaut
peut-être perdre 100 g que d'en perdre 1
kg donc on va préférer multiplier les
livraisons le réapprovisionnement de
points plutôt que d'avoir des
approvisionnements plus espacés mais
avec des plus grosses quantités voilà
donc ça c'est le le le type de réseau
qu'on qu'on peut que l'on peut auquel on
est confronté et pour répondre à l'autre
question que vous aviez sur
l'identification des ce qu'on appelle
l'identification des avoirs criminels
mais on on travaille alors déjà en
première intention demande à nos
enquêteurs de systématiquement avoir un
volet patrimonial pour ne pas ne pas
s'intéresser uniquement à
l'environnement de la personne son
adresse son numéro de téléphone avec qui
elle vit comment elle se déplace mais
également voilà est-ce qu'elle a des
comptes bancaires est-ce qu'elle a des
assurances vie avec quoi elle roule à
qui appartient le véhicule parce que ça
c'est une des grandes difficultés
lorsqu'on parlait de simplification de
la procédure évidemment que nos
trafiquants ont bien compris que il
n'était plus question d'avoir un
véhicule à son nom donc au-delà de
l'utilisation des véhicules de lo ation
qui est une autre problématique le
véhicule qu'ils utilisent peuvent être
acheté par eux mais mis au nom d'un
tiers la difficulté pour nous c'est
qu'il faut requalifier la propriété
c'està-dire pour pour pouvoir saisir il
faut qu'on puisse établir que ce
véhicule soit n'est pas au nom du
trafiquant mais c'est lui qui l'utilise
c'est lui qui paye l'assurance c'est lui
qui paye l'essence c'est lui qui
l'utilise systématiquement pour ce
trafic mais tout cela moi je le dis
c'est simple mais quand le major doit le
matérialiser par parce que qu'en face on
va nous dire bah oui mais vous nous avez
vu une fois mais une fois ne veut pas
dire propriété donc nous on va devoir
amener au magistrat le fait que c'est
pas une fois c'est 5 10 c'est quotidien
c'est hebdomadaire voilà donc tout ça
l'air de rien ça demande énormément de
travail et sans être sûr qu'à la fin
cette recqualification de la propriété
soit acceptée et qu'on puisse saisir le
véhicule et mais voilà et pour finir
peut-être j'en finis là je te laisse la
parole on travaille évidemment avec les
Gires et on travaille avec la CC les
cellules régionales d'avoir criminel qui
nous aide qui qui nous apporte une aide
une aide assez inestimable en la
matière je vais juste compléter les
propos de mon camarade mais complet il y
a deux choses là quand vous évoquez le
trafic en fait quand on arrive à à
finiser les trafic et justement en
préparant cette intervention je regarder
un peu tout ce qui avait été fait on
arrive à voir c'est pour ça je donnis le
profil par exemple du télépilote de
drone qui avait été livré là le centre
pénitentier c'est qu'on arrive à
détecter un peu les profil et ce qui est
intéressant de comprendre c'est la
motivation de chacun donc la motivation
c'est l'intérêt financier que peut
générer et aussi sur des trafics plus
petits puisqu'on arrive en bout dechaîne
souvent dans la ruralité vous avez des
revendeurs il y a aussi la personne qui
revend juste pour sa simple consommation
voilà et après euh je vous donnerai un
exempleà preuve qu'il s'adapte voyez
quand il y a eu la période des périodes
des des perquisitions administratives
qu'on faisait pour un tout autre objet
suite aux attentats on faisait des
perquisitions à toute heure de la
journée de la nuit et normalement les
perquisitions en droit commun vous savez
6h 21h donc ça nous arrivait
régulièrement sur des cibles de taper à
2 3h du matin et là c'était pas r alors
qu'on était pas là pour ça de faire des
grosses saisies parce qu'ils s'y
attendaient pas on arrivit chez des gens
où là ils avaient des grosses quantités
ça veut dire qu'à part partir de 6h du
matin c'est parti pour dire que voilà il
s'adapte réellement et après sur la le
patrimoine quand on travaille aussi
c'est important aussi de pouvoir faire
ce travail de au-delà des avoirs
criminels mais c'est ce qui nous
intéresse à la fin aussi d'aller
chercher le le bien Malaki comme dirait
la grâce mais c'est aussi d'avoir le
train de vie c'est-à-dire que ça va nous
aider dans les investigations de savoir
que telle personne alors je vais vous
donner un exemple d'un trafic on avait
fait justement alors là c'était pas dans
l'ordre mais c'était dans le nord de la
France où on avait tout un groupe de
jeunes de délinquants qui changeaient de
véhicule de location toutes les semaines
donc vous voyez quand il changeent de
véhicule toutes les semaines ça veut
dire toutes les semaines il faut
rebaliser les véhicules et ça veut dire
aussi qu'en les suivant on arriva à se
rendre compte qu'il ils dor dans des
hôtels donc pour les loger on était dans
des hôtels très régulièrement toutes les
semaines et ça vous donne le train de
vie quand vous avez des jeunes des gens
pas stigmatiser voilà tel ou tel mais
quand vous avez des individus qui
travaillent pas et qui toutes les
semaines ils achètent enfin il lou des
véhicules de location en plus des belles
voitures qui mangent à l'extérieur tous
les jours et qui ont un trad de vie qui
va au-delà de ce qui gagne réellement ça
vous permet aussi de matérialiser le
trafic parce qu'il faut bien que
l'argent vienne de quelque part donc
tout ça c'est un c'est en fait c'est un
travail global quoi finalement parce que
on a besoin de le faire et au-delà de ça
aussi il y a aussi une histoire de on se
plaignait de enfin on se plaignait on
aimerait bien avoir la l'identification
de de la messagerie cryptée mais tous
ces moyens de paiement tous ces
paiements qui sont fait à extérieur ça
nous permet aussi c'est des des moyens
d'investigation
pour les les identifier à tel et tel
endroit c'est une traçabilité aussi avec
votre carte bleue aujourd'hui vous êtes
al je veux pas donner d'idée mais voyez
on arrive aussi à remonter tout ça grâce
au moyen de paiement quoi ou
voilà mariearlette Carlotti merci
monsieur le Président merci à à vous
quatre pour vos interventions et puis
sur le travail pour le travail que vous
menez sur le terrain dans le cadre de la
lutte contre les stupéfiants
permettez-moi de vous interroger sur les
enquêtes judiciaires vous avez dit tout
à l'heure que vous avez de très bonnes
relations avec la police judiciaire que
vous travaillez dans de très bonnes
collaboration de toute façon s'il y
avait une faille les mafieux en
profiteraient toutes les failles sont
bonnes pour eux alors y y a-t-il des
failles comment se fait cette
coordination cette collaboration et
est-ce qu'il y a des choses à améliorer
quant au moyen vous avez déjà répondu au
rapporteur tout à
l'heure alors je juste apporter une
toute petite précision que je je
comprends vre question vous disz qu' on
avait des relations avec la police
judiciaire alors je en terme de police
judiciaire malheureusement le les le
vocabulaire à son importance là en en
l'occurrence nous nous sommes au
quotidien euh au côté de nos camarades
de la police nationale mais qui sont
alors il il ne s'agit plus de parler de
sécurité publique maintenant puisque la
la structuration a changé mais nous nous
sommes nous sommes au contact de nos
camarades du commissariat de
Saint-Quentin pas de la police
judiciaire pas de la police judiciaire
pas de la dzpj de du du Nord en revanche
au sein du commissaire c'est le
commissaire Saint-Quentin accueille la
ce qu'il était convenu d'appeler la
sûreté départementale qui s'appelle
maintenant si j'ai bien compris le
service départemental de police
judiciaire euh comme ça s'appelait
d'ailleurs au niveau de la préfecture de
police de Paris mais bref euh voilà donc
nous avons de effectivement de bonnes
relations avec eux
alors les failles qui pourraent
exister effectivement le l'absence
l'absence d'échange de renseignement
pourrait effectivement constituer une
faille dans laquelle les trafiquants euh
pourrai pourrait venir pour pour venir
s'insinuer euh après je sais que genre
je parlerai pas pour eux mais je sais
que mes camarades de de de la police de
laine ont aussi les mêmes difficulté que
nous sur le le le le volume d'affaires à
traiter et et les moyens mis en
adéquation donc oui ça peut être une
difficulté en tout cas moi ce que je
peux
témoigner vu de ma place de grand
compagnie de Saint-Quentin c'est que dès
que nous avons besoin d'échanger avec
nos camarades policiers ça se passe très
bien et qu'il n'y a pas de concurrence
et que au contraire si on peut s'appuyer
les uns les autres ça ça se passe tout à
fait correctement après avec la police
judiciaire à mon niveau en compagnie on
n pas de relation
autre vous vouzer je vous en
prie pour compléter en fait sur la
relation qu'on peut avoir avec les
services de police déjà il y a un
service une relation quotidienne en tant
que chef de service donc on se voit et
elle est aussi alors soit elle est
organisée elle est informelle c'est ce
qui se passe au quotidien nos enquêteurs
des unités de recherche pour les voir
régulièrement ils vont au contact des
camarades de la police nationale aussi
pour échanger parce que voilà on se
donne voilà moi chez moi j'ai un secteur
police à alançon et argenttin si on
croit qu'il y a une il y a pas de
porosité entre les deux secteurs poliis
gendarmerie donc on est obligé de se
parler parce que les derni CS il restent
pas dans leur zone donc on le fait et
aussi au-delà de des des contacts
informels qu'on a on a des structures
alors sous l'gide des parquets déjà moi
j'ai j'ai au moins deux réunions par
mois avec les les procureurs et autour
de la table on a la procure de la
République la police nationale et la
gendarmerie ce qui nous permet aussi
d'échanger sur des stratégies d'enquête
donc je suis aussi au courant des
enquêtes en cours donc voilà il y a des
lieux qui sont prmis dédié et puis aussi
ce qui concerne alors là c'est pour la
partie parquet mais pour la partie hord
de République avec les sous-préfectures
d'arrondissement on a aussi des échanges
sur tout ce qui concerne l'ordre public
et la police nationale est aussi présent
donc on a des lieux dédiés quoroise
quimentroise qutien vous n'avez pas
mentionné le Fast quels sont vos
rapports avec le
fast
alors pour le coup et je je laisserai
mon camarade répondre pour lui mais je
pense queil va avoir la même réponse que
moi en tant qu' compagnie vous n'avez
pas de rapport avec le Fast vous n'en
avez pas parce que alors je parce qu'on
est pas au même niveau d'investigation
mais voilà nous n'avons pas de contact
direct avec le
Fast alors oui attention enfin ça ça ne
veut pas dire que ça nous est interdit
on pourrait tout à fait effectivement
être contacté par l'ofast qui viendrait
effectivement nous nous tasquer pour
nous dire voilà on a un dossier qui
pourrait avoir un rapport avec la
circonscription en tout cas moi depuis
que je suis présent ça ça n'a pas été le
cas ça ça ne s'est pas produit en fait
je je rejoins ce que mon camarade vient
de dire et sur le niveau de l'oface on
n'est pas au bon niveau parce qu'on a la
section de recherche genderie pour ça et
après on a les contacts sdrdrt enfin les
renseignements territoriaux qui eux ont
des contacts et là c'est pareil avec
l'arrondissement on a des contacts aussi
avec eux donc pas directement mais
indirectement oui ouais oui ah bien sûr
oui qu'il faut ou oui aujour'i ave
l'organisation qui est la vôtre vous
avez le sentiment que vous constituez
une digue contre le déferlement de
stupéfiant sur le territoire
national vous avez le sentiment que vous
vivez un peu l'océan avec un un L à cou
vous avez le sentiment d'être efficace
et qu quel est votre ressenti sur sur
le le véritable fléau que ça constitue
et l'importance que ça prend si entre 4
et 6 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires est-ce que vous estimez que
vous êtes à la dimension de
l'enjeu question difficile vous avez 2
heur voilà si si si on a un petit peu de
préparation
alorsfin je je je vais pas me défiler je
vais vous répondre mais juste pour vous
dire que vu le vu le la le niveau de
votre question un commandant de
compagnie en tant commandant de
compagnie j'ai un petit peu de mal à
vous répondre sur sur la globalité mais
sur notre secteur alors j'ai envie de
vous dire que OUI à toutes vos questions
dans le sens où oui j'ai l'impression de
vider un peu le la mer avec une petite
cuillère l'océan avec une petite
cuillère mais oui j'ai quand même
l'impression que notre travail est
indispensable
et apporte quand même ses fruits voilà
mais
on on pourrait on pourrait peut-être
être encore plus efficace mais
aujourd'hui nous parlons de de de
narcotrafic et c'est bien normal puisque
c'est le sujet de de de votre commission
d'enquête nous en tant que commandant de
compagnie on a effectivement ce sujet
qui est une de nos priorités c'est clair
mais Ismaël tout à l'heure évoqué les
vifs les vifs sont une priorité la lutte
contre les cambriolages sont une
priorité le la surveillance du
territoire est évidemment une priorité
c'est c'est ce qui constitue l'essence
même de la gendarmerie l'addition des
priorités fait que on on on essaie de
travailler sur toutes mais on peut pas
forcément être complètement efficace sur
chacune
juste pour compléter la la question du
rapporteur euh s'il y avait une
disposition une mesure un moyen qui vous
permettrait de d'enregistrer un pas
décisif sur cette question particulière
des stupéfiants est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose qui spontanément vous vient à
l'esprit terme d'organisation je pas av
citer les messageries tout à l'heure
est-ce que est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui
est alors euh j'ai un passé d'enquêteur
comme mon camarade mais donc je vais me
faire violence sur le fait que s'il
devait y en avoir qu'une je dirais que
appuyer la lutte contre la contre la
consommation et appuyer sur le sur les
consommateurs même si naturellement
j'aurais envie de vous dire que les
moyens les moyens d'enquête les
techniques d'enquête et que les moyens
les et et que l'aspect législatif sur
sur la procédure assez naturellement
viendra en premier en premier ressort
mais je pense que la si je reste
persuadé peut-être que c'est un
résidement un peu basico basique mais
moins de consommateurs moins de
vendeurs je vais pour pour répondre en
fait j'aurais du mal à vous répondre
parce que comme mon camarade disait
effectivement on est sur tous les tout
le spectre en même temps et en même
temps je dirais la la difficulté pour
avoir travaillé sur un spectre plus haut
pour le coup parce que effffectivement
comme il le disait on a servi en unité
de recherche avant d'être commandant de
compagnie là on est sur un spectre où on
s'aperçoit que c'est un peu tout le
monde et c'est pour ça que je donnerai
la parole à la j Chenet ça peut être
intéressant de voir aussi on eff face à
un problème de santé publique c'est sûr
et dans le cadre du contrôle des flux de
le JCF la création du JCF vous allez
voir que il fait des contrôle sur la par
exemple par voie ferroviaire aussi
beaucoup dans les trains donc il
peut-être l'occasion de vous expliquer
et voir le profil de personnes qu'on a
en fait on est plus sur le délinquant
qu'on imagine avec la grosse voiture en
fait on est sur tout donc je je pense
que voilà ça pourrait être intéressant
je chef de nous justement notre unité on
cherche le consommateur on cherche à
harceler le consommateur pour le
groupement de l'ordre en gros c'est une
AFD établie tous les de jours à 4 donc
c'est quand même assez conséquent et il
y a aucun profil c'est qu'on va aussi
bien du jeune de 18 ans à la mê de 82
ans ça nous arrivé il y a 15 jours à une
petite dame qui avait son petit morceau
de résine
thérapeutique voilà donc il n'y a aucun
profil et nous justement on pour
reprendre un peu l'expression on comble
un peu le trou dans la raquette on fait
les micro trafic vraiment au niveau
local et on on tape sur la confiscation
sur des choses comme ça on fait beaucoup
d'avoirs criminels à notre niveau mais
voilà en fait les les profils et les
motivations sont tellement différents
que enfin je pense à mon niveau et à la
tête de la compagnie que avoir
l'impression de de tout miser sur un un
dispositif ça marchera pas en fait il
faut que la réponse elle peut être que
globale c'estàd de faire tout ce qu'on
fait là en même temps travailler sur les
petits consommateurs en même temps
travailler sur les gros trafics en même
temps travailler sur la gestion des flux
travailler dans les trains voilà Paris
Grandville ENF d'être présent dans les
trains d'être présent sur la route si on
fait pas ça tout en même temps voilà la
réponse estelle est
multiple
oui bon c'est la parole de l'enquêteur
mais c'est vrai que les messageries
crypté restent quand même un souci
actuellement puisque bon on a des
techniques forcément les écoutes
téléphoniques et cetera mais on voit
bien qu'il y a des trous voilà on a des
échanges qu'on a pas forcément et on
sait très bien que ça passe par des
messagescryp et on a d'ailleurs les
preuves maintenant ils installent des
gens et ils lui disent voilà Touvre
parle la messagerie signal WhatsApp et
cetera pour pas qu'on puisse suivre sur
les téléphones donc c'est un vrai
problème est-ce que du côté de mes
collègues il y a des questions
remarques le rapporteur semble avoir
obtenu des réponses aux siennes mais il
nous reste à vous remercier
chaleureusement pour pour votre pour
cette audition vous souhaite
effectivement bon courage pour ce
travail de fond et puis je crois que
vous avez aussi des demande de de
confirmation par écrit de ce que vous
avez dit devant nous aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup messsieur bon retour dans vos
territoire